[Music]
good morning everyone
how's everyone doing my name is Pierce
Malik I'm a vice president at Spring ml
a premier partner to Google cloud in the
area of machine learning and data
analytics and today we will be talking
about predictive maintenance and IOT and
ml I'll be joined by my colleagues
Manuel from Springer mal and Prashant
from Google and we'll go through this
but just before we get started I want to
get a sense of the audience here and
bright light from the back so by show of
hands how many of you are data
scientists machine learning specialists
all right how many are I Oh tea
specialists ok great and how many are
sea level or execs are Business
Development guys oh okay all right good
good mix so I would say right in the
middle 33% each so I think we should
have enough for all of you in this
presentation advanced
do I need to point to something to get
it to advance it's not advancing
so while the clicker gets to work so
predictive maintenance and IOT now today
the agenda is we'll start with some
industry scenarios to get everybody
level set on predictive maintenance then
we'll talk about how Google IOT cloud
core the cloud IOT core is a platform
for predictive maintenance then we will
come to the specific a demo that we've
got for oil and gas industry I mean a
solution that we've built using these
components and thirdly we will come to a
client case where we will talk about how
we've done something like this and how
we can put to practice and finally we'll
get to the future and what's what's lies
ahead okay all right so this is the
agenda that we went through the clicker
is not working all right okay so in the
area of asset management No okay
all right just by show of hands how many
of you think this hypothesis is true
everything needs maintenance all right
okay good
pull that thought and we'll come back to
it now typically in industry heavy
equipment has a lifespan of anywhere
between thirty to sixteen years right
but and and it's very difficult to
replace these equipment but if the
breakdown happens it leads to loss of
productivity loss of profit and so and
so forth now how do you avoid this
costly downtime of course he'll say
maintenance now you know another thing
that managers deal in manufacturing is
the operational equipment efficiency and
the legacy industry assets are you know
have been in practice for 30 40 years
now there are techniques that have been
followed till now which are time-based
and they basically use statistics from
the past runs and they compile those and
make a best guess at how to prevent the
problems now let's take a couple of
industry scenarios I'm assuming all of
you travel by air right now
can someone tell me how many components
this particular this particular engine
has this is a Boeing 747 any any guesses
out there shut it out
very close so about 25,000 and this
particular engine at this particular
flight typically generates a terabyte of
data per flight now there are sensors in
all these 25,000 components in the
engine and if they could talk to each
other and if they could those sensors
could be analyzed that is the heartbeat
that we need to listen to and we need to
avoid catastrophic situations and of
course I don't know about you but I have
spent many hours sitting on the tarmac
waiting for the maintenance person to
come and fix the problem in the aircraft
I'm sure many of you can relate to it as
well
so let's move on to an oil and gas
production rig and these are massive
equipment whether it's at land or in the
ocean they need to have some goals to
meet production output as well as it
needs to be safe operations so human
lives are at stake
and environmental regulations are also
important so each of these rigs also has
about 30,000 components but today less
than 1% of that data is being used to
make decisions we need to change that
let's move to manufacturing industry
same scenario lot of complex operations
lot of components
now these automation and as we are
getting into the world of robotics and
increased automation it'll be this
scenario will be even more important you
cannot afford to have a manufacturing
line stop in between so the best way is
to optimize this by keeping workers safe
and avoid costly shutdowns
and prevent disruption so again
maintenance is key so having established
that we did some study of you know
various analysts and various industry
bodies and this is what they found about
40% of preventive maintenance costs are
spent on assets with negligible impact
on uptime 30% of preventative
maintenance are carried out too
frequently which are not needed and 45%
of main efforts are ineffective what
does this tell us this tells us that
that that time based approach is not
going to work for the future and we need
a condition based monitoring and at the
same time as we know the there are
components which talk to each other we
need to be able to harness that data and
have the ability to not only store but
also analyze the data on the edge so to
summarize the business benefits of
predictive maintenance I think we've
established different industries needed
and again whether it is a fortune or
whether it is a McKinsey all these
studies point to the various elements
here that you know by using predictive
maintenance you can do a lot better with
with your maintenance activity then keep
your equipment up you can reduce the
maintenance cost by up to 25% you can
eliminate breakdowns by 70% so and so
forth so I will I will also say that you
know you are able to give their benefit
back to your shareholders by using
predictive maintenance for the sea level
exact here the audience now it's no no
strange news to you that our
is interconnected and some of the
studies that have been done talk about
how there would be more than 220 billion
devices with sensors Gartner says twenty
point four billion devices are connected
today and by 2020 there'll be 50 billion
devices but if only one person of
savings by using IOT is applied in oil
and gas they could save ninety billion
dollars think about the impact this has
and overall IOT market is a three
trillion dollar market now this is the
perfect segue into talking about cloud
IOT core this is a product which is a
fully managed platform for producing
insights from sensors coming from at a
very rapid pace hundreds of thousands of
events happening in real-time are able
we are able to analyze that using GCP
and specifically cloud IOT core and
using predictive techniques as opposed
to time-based maintenance can definitely
result in savings as well as the safety
of the operators and there are certain
features here I want to mention here
there are two components there is a
device gateway and and there are ability
to process this data in real time and
there are some more features that Google
today announced so for that I would like
to invite fresh on tone safe to talk
about them Shawn thanks Josh
hi my name is bhishan ting I work as a
machine learning leader at Google like a
speech mentioned cloud IOT core is a
fully managed service this is an entry
point to ingest data from cloud IOT and
then you can apply machine learning or
data processing component however there
is a need to do data processing where
the data exists which is on the edge so
there is a research from IDC that 40% of
the data needs to be processed where it
will start it originated from and there
are six billion
devices get added every day so there are
a number of reason why you need to
process data at the edge so latency and
bandwidth is is the primary reason for
example if you are doing fraud detection
on a credit card you want to determine
the fraud as someone is swiping the card
so there is no time left to take the
data from credit card and take it to the
edge or take it to the cloud and then do
the prediction so there is a latency
requirement in many scenarios where it
is important to do the prediction at the
edge similarly if you have a data in
machinery or in aircraft and ships
sometimes there are latency requirement
that require immediate action bandwidth
is also another issue so if if you are
doing predictive maintenance on a ship
sometimes the ships are in the sea and
many times during the war time they do
not have the right bandwidth or
connectivity so there is a requirement
or a compliance requirement that
prediction should should happen even in
the even if there is no network
connectivity there are privacy issues
also like some of the data is not safe
to transmit over the networks that's
that's another benefit of doing the
prediction on edge and as I mentioned
like connectivity might be an issue like
when in a machinery the machines are not
always connected ships or aircraft are
not always connected and there are cost
benefit also if you can do the
prediction on an edge you can save
sending all the data to a cloud so these
were the driving factors that for that
Google took into account and today they
announced ml on edge so in future you
will be able to do data processing as
well as you will be able to like do the
machine learning on edge device even
before today
they were component availables but they
were not managed component for example
there's a component called tensorflow
light that takes your machine learning
model you can compress the machine
learning model and make it as smaller
and you can deploy it on a as device so
even today you can do it but from
tomorrow on what it will become much
easier for you because there will be a
managed service and that many service is
called cloud IOT h it has two pieces it
has a ml n HL edge IOT core so earlier
we discussed like
cloud IOT is a managed service on a
cloud but edge ml and edge IOT core will
exist on your devices and you will be
able to run it on Android things or any
Linux or based operating system so there
are you might have also heard about STP
use so I just wanted to call out the
difference between the two as TPU is a
chip based hardware device and a cloud
IOT edge is a software stack so they
they work together so in a cloud IOT
edge you can decide to do data
processing or machine learning using CPU
GPUs or TP use so if you if you have a
requirement where you need to use TP use
you can use STP use to do prediction on
very complex model so your overall
architecture will look like that you
will do the edge ml on a device and then
you will take that data take it to cloud
you will do the training there on
aggregate data you'll build a model and
deploy it on various devices this is a
more complex version of the previous ml
lifecycle so which component you will
use you will use edge ml and agile T
core on a device cloud IOT core is for
connectivity of device and you can use
iot function or pub/sub to aggregate the
data or data flow to process the data
and then you can store the data into big
table bigquery or
and you can once you have store the data
you can do training using cloud machine
learning so this would be an end-to-end
architecture and using this you will be
able to build powerful predictive
maintenance model which you can run it
on a cloud as well as you can deploy it
on an edge device thus all push this is
awesome I mean we got the latest
information from this morning and we
were able to incorporate during the
presentation so that's awesome now let's
talk about a solution that we had spring
ml have built using IOT core and ml and
what is the problem that again going
back to the predictive maintenance
scenario if somebody has to maintain
equipment they've got to keep spare
parts right if you have too much of
spare parts available
that's like capital bound or wasted
capital you want to optimize on that and
if you don't have the right component
available when machine breakdown happens
then again there is a loss of
productivity so how do you get around
this and this is a solution we will show
how and we'll give you a demo as well
how it brings it together so as we have
been talking about sensors in the
components in the machines talk all we
have to do is listen to the machines the
machines are telling you when they need
help not time-based it's not like your
car has an auto meter of ten thousand
miles and it needs oil change no not
anymore or for that matter any boat that
is traveling in sea and it needs change
of an engine because it has run for so
many hours
it is the components which look at wear
and tear look at temperature humidity
and so and so forth and this solution
brings all of that together using the
concept of remaining useful life and
again we used cloud IOT core and the
sensor data was read in a secure fashion
in real time and we executed machine
learning model to get predictions and
this is a simplified architecture
it might look but let me just simplify
it for you the Gateway the sensor data
comes in cloud pub/sub which can handle
lots of events per second in hundreds of
thousands and it is able to process the
data through the pipeline and various
components for either storing or doing
analytics on the cloud and it can be
deployed for for the users there so with
that of course this benefit of this
solution is it provides deep
understanding of your asset performance
in real-time and proactive alerts are
sent out so with that I want to invite
my colleague Manuel to give a demo of
the
solution that we built you could get the
slides back please thank you so I'm
gonna walk you through a demo we built
around the oil refinery industry and
it's the showcase IOT core and also the
how it fits in the GCP it turns out one
thing that was interested in in building
this demo was to understand the big
picture it turns out IOT core is
actually not the bottleneck it works
really well it's very easy to use you
plug in your sensors and you get your
data the problem is you end up with a
deluge of data there's just too much an
avalanche of data and how would you deal
with it and that's when the whole GCP
you know pipeline starts making sense
especially if you want to run IOT models
at scale you need to you need all these
all the pieces that are tied after that
fit in after IOT core have to be able to
scale have to be able to reduce your
data have to be able to deal with so you
can learn about it so first off before I
go into demo let me just talk about some
of the challenges you need enough
historical data to run these models in
our case we're looking at time series
it's like survival analysis so you'll
need enough data from the time you turn
the machine on to the time the machine
dies right you need to have enough of
these historical cases in order to run
these kind of models to train these kind
of also learn what features you know
indicate a failure and if it's not time
series if it's a binary you'll need
enough of your whatever the minority
case is in order to learn if it's multi
classification you'll need to have
enough of each class to be able to
properly train a model and that's
nothing to do with IOT right that's just
machine learning in general same thing
with selecting the right model because
we're talking about Big Data we're
talking about big data streaming you
gotta find models that work in the cloud
that you can mount easily in cloud MLE
that can handle the this huge amount of
throughput and I'll talk about this
after the demo and of course what is the
what is your end product right is going
to be a dashboard an alerting system
does it feed into some you know some
some other tool so all these things have
to be thought of
as a big picture the IOT is is more than
just the IOT core it's a lot of
different pieces and can I have the my
machine now please so here I mean I'm in
I'm in Google Cloud and I have a virtual
machine ready to go and I'm gonna create
some I'm gonna simulate some machine
data and I'll talk about where that data
came from in a minute we're gonna wait
it it's gonna generate it's gonna
generate two machine two engines and
it's going to create a you know simulate
a bunch of sensors per machine
I'll give it a minute I mean a couple
seconds till it starts there it is there
it comes in and now I can go to the demo
we have a website there it is so yeah so
the two points so you could have you
know you know a thousand of these these
are oil rigs so each green dot on the
map is an oil rig we have two just for
this demo North Dakota and Kansas and I
can click on any of them I'll choose the
one in Kansas and then you see a green
dot that appears a green dot that
appears you could have multiple machines
on its trick again for the simplicity of
this demo we're just using one and here
we click on it and in this case just for
the the closure of this demo we're
building a dashboard so the top part you
have the predictive side right so this
is what the the engine learned and now
we're saying that the this engine right
is currently has plenty of life left so
normally these engines would break down
in years of course here we're doing it
in minutes for the demo but as long as
it's in the green zone it's safe if it
gets the yellow you know that's when you
would fire off alerts text or you know
or whatever needs to be done or
temporary turn down a machine to swap a
piece when it's in danger zone is just
bad so the second level here you have
these are the real-time indicators it
tells you basically what the the machine
that the ml model is is using our this
is the same data so we're presenting
real-time data like cable tension oil
temperature etc that's what the the
model is using to predict the the above
bar right whether it's healthy or not
healthy or in danger and lower we have a
bunch of historical indicators and
that's just recording the data through
time so that you know we can see how it
how the you know how it's how it's
progressing through time and before
failure and I am gonna go back to the
map and I'll bring it back when it's in
a yellow state but can I get the slides
back please thank you so high level
there's there's a deeper view later on
but a very high level you have you have
the Python simulator that is you know
pumping data into IOT core right so
these are the sensors into IOT core IOT
core then messages it out to pops up
right pops up is this massive message
queuing system and it publishes it out
and we have data flow as a subscriber so
data flow so when you have a subscribed
you're always guaranteed to get every
packet at least once from pub/sub that's
the guarantee it does the contract and
data flow can do a lot here we're just
scratching the surface of what data flow
can do it can do aggregation it can do
data transformation it can do MapReduce
that cancer so these are tools all these
tools can are designed to scale and
handle a huge amounts of data so it's
not just IOT core anymore it's
everything in the pipeline that needs to
be able to handle what you're what
you're throwing at it and data flow will
transform the data pass it to the the
regressor model here the deep neural
network regressor to get the prediction
and all that data is stored in bigquery
and bigquery massive you know a data
warehouse I was reading a 35 billion you
could you could you could query 35
billion rows of data with no indexes in
seconds right and it just it's like
you're it's funny because we work a lot
with bigquery and you're typing selects
star or select whatever fields from and
it just feels like you're you're
querying your local your local database
on your machine what and you're like
whatever right it ran it's good but in
reality what's happening behind is it
could be querying you know thousands of
machines all around the world and it
just feels like I said your local
machine so that's a phenomenal tool
great to work with and I'm going to talk
a bit about the data we're using so
we're using this data set called modular
Aero propulsion system simulation Maps
it's made available it's open source
made available by NASA and these are
turbofan engines from life to death and
they made that public so we are basing
our data
we're sim
data based on on that and that was very
useful for us because we're talking
about real machine data with a series of
sensors and there are 22 in total and
here you would you would you would you
know you would train your model for IOT
just like you train any other model
right you'll do your figure out if your
features are significant you'll figure
out variable importance and for example
in this case we found a bunch that we're
not helping the model we threw them out
and we just kept you know the ones that
that were that were of use just like you
would you know model anything any other
model in terms of the the the the models
we use so we tried a whole bunch this is
time series data so we tried LS TMS we
tried widened D progressor it's a very
popular model that is part of the
estimator API but in the end that the
estimator DNN regressor was a simplest
really transparent model and worked
really well and i'll say a few words
here about the estimator api because
this is really huge in tensorflow most
of the the tensorflow code you'll see
online may not fit easily into cloud MLE
into the cloud machine learning engine
and when you're talking about modeling
at scale predicting at scale you've got
to make sure that your model can be
distributed to you know thousands of
machines it needs to be so you need to
comply with the way cloud MLE can handle
your tensorflow model and if you follow
the the estimator the api you'll
automatically get inherit the classes
that deployment class is the training
test classes only sinks and even if you
want to do a more complex it does have a
bunch of built-in models like DNN
regressor and a wide and deep but if you
need to do really complex custom models
you can still inherit from the base
class of TF estimator and you and you
will benefit from the exact functions
you need to be able to deploy it to the
cloud so I can have my machine back for
a minute please
so just just want to highlight that
right so now both of these machines are
in are in alert state so this would be
when you would start sending out you
know SMS is text update dashboards you
know fire off alarms kanata slides back
please and eventually they'll turn to
red but I think I don't need to be late
on that and I'll talk about a scoring in
a minute
so I'm gonna leave that one so here is
how you would call this this regressor
model part of the estimator API it's
super simple right you just you just
call it and really all you need really
is just you know just give it your
hidden units right and even I think he
would do default to hidden units for you
but you can say you know how many hidden
layers you want the sizes you want here
we're calling in the optimizer you don't
even have to do that if you don't want
to but it's nice because you can pass it
your your l1 and your learning rate
right but you don't even need to do that
so that permits you to to not worry too
much about you know mucking around with
this stuff and think about what your
your business use case is what's really
important right because these things
work they're well done you can you can
trust them and they do expose a series
of parameters that you need but you
don't have to worry too much about the
rest and this is really frees us to kind
of say ok we know it's from the the
estimator API is going to be able to be
mounted in cloud MLE fine and you can
move on and think about what you know
what your business is all about in terms
of score I'm gonna just briefly talk
about this we got a a route route square
meter a root mean squared error of 45
that means there's about 350 on average
cycles per engine in in our in our in
our demo data and that means we're
correct we're plus or minus correct on
45 cycles and Prashant was just telling
me that they worked on this model and
this data said more and they even go and
got it down to 5 so more feature
engineering more you know you can you
can work you can work this number a lot
lower but this was in line with the
papers on that data set we saw so we
were satisfied just for the demos sake
ok so here's a more precise you know a
schema of of the model so you see the
the Python is is passing the the
simulated data to the IOT core IOT
course passing it the pub/sub pops up is
passing it a data flow so this is where
we see more precision and the other
chart are showing you before data flow
can do a lot of things it can be like
your your your your data manager your
your your choreographer here in this
case so it's doing multiple things it's
preparing the data so you can pass it to
the DNN regressor model which is mounted
in Google Cloud through Cloud Emily and
it's also so this is the prediction and
it's also passing the real-time data to
bigquery bigquery as I mentioned it's a
industrial-strength
data warehouse it's a bottomless pit you
can just keep throwing that it will just
distribute in the background so that's
when you start seeing these these more
sophisticated models right it's not no
more you have one model yielding a
prediction now you have you know many
models and it could have many models
many different processes handling the
data and the output is everything right
it's going to be bigquery is going to
give you give our visualization layer
that dashboard I was showing you is
going to give the prediction that was a
top part it's also going to give the
real-time data right so because we're
pumping all the data into bigquery you
just take whatever features you have the
latest timestamp and those are your you
know your real time your real time
values for your features of whatever
machine you're looking at and also a
historical data right because you can
put in it and all that can be queried in
bigquery so bigquery is actually
yielding three different values the
predictions the current values and the
historical data so a pretty powerful
tool very easy to work with and in terms
of training I'll close this by saying a
few things if you know if an engine is
gonna break down on average to every 3m
every three years right maybe every six
months you could retrain right if the
model you feel is drifting you could
also build some continuous like online
modeling where it's continually you know
reassessing the data the the only caveat
and something that we all have to think
about when we're building these models
is if you if you retrain on model where
you have done something on where you
have taken action on a prediction your
data becomes tainted not tainted but
it's just different right so we need to
segregate what data you have taken an
action on because of a prediction from
your model versus what was left alone so
in case if you're doing another round
you probably would have to do two
separate models right or just choose
which one you want to work with and this
is just quick quick recap over the the
what we saw so this is a healthy healthy
machine everything looks like it's in
the green we have the historical values
and now here we have it is broken right
it's in the danger zone and we can see
we have some extremes and that's what
the model would use there is you know we
started with 17 features so there are
more than just those four and that's it
I'm gonna pass it back to P use
Thank You maro
so hopefully you got a sense of how we
bid the solutions and now coming to real
life client projects obviously as I told
you spring ml is an application provider
and specialized your partner to Google
in machine learning and data analytics
so this is how we execute projects with
client problems essentially we want to
make sure we understand the business
problem so we heavily partner with the
clients after the understanding of the
business domain and putting the data
scientists and data engineers together
we do the step of data creation and as
Manuel alluded to data preparation is
the toughest part and in fact data
munging
or data wrangling I call it data
scientists tend to spend more than 75 to
80 percent of their time doing that and
once the data is prepped
we've got determine the right features
and as we discussed there are models ml
models that have to be built and they
have to be trained and then they have to
be deployed so to do this and bring to
life I will talk about a real clients
case and the client is a leader in the
telematics industry one of the largest
users of Google cloud platform in Canada
and as it so happens I have Mike branch
the VP of data and analytics from geo
table with me Mike why don't you come on
stage with me please welcome all right
so thank you thank you so so Mike as you
saw how we executed in the project
partnering with Google and yourself we
went through this project maybe almost
more than six months back and we just
published by the way a case study on
this last week and that's the reason why
Mike is here right now
and the problem that we had at this in
this particular project was to find out
what's the utilization how a particular
their fleet is being used but more
before I get into that I would want Mike
to say what geotab does and what's so
special about this project yeah
absolutely so um geo top first of all
were the second largest provider of
telematics in the world right now so we
track about 1.2 million commercial
vehicles and the raw data that's coming
into our ecosystem is about 3 billion
raw records on a daily basis so the
device plugs into the onboard diagnostic
port of a vehicle tracks everything from
you know harsh braking erratic driving
events seatbelt buckled unbuckled engine
rpm the likes and but Amy the biggest
challenge with all of this data with 1.2
million vehicles is how do you figure
out how the vehicles are driving if I'm
gonna benchmark my customers and
benchmark them for productivity or for
idling or for fuel usage fuel economy I
need to do it based on the vocation of
the vehicle not the industry that the
vehicle is in industry just doesn't make
sense it's how you drive your vehicle
and what is its purpose in life so that
was the difficult challenge that we had
when we brought in the guys at Google
and the guys at spring and melody they
gave us a hand and and that's important
for us from a benchmarking perspective
but then also from the perspective of
understanding you know if I'm looking at
smart city applications
what does freight movement look like
within a city right so that's where
these guys were able to really really
shine and give us a hand here right so
again look at the slide out here which
outlines what the problem was and what
we delivered and multiple statistical
models and using machine learning again
this slide says 1.1 million obviously
they have grown since the time we did
the project sorry said 1.2 million so I
stand corrected here and there's a quote
from as well so thank you very much for
being a customer and I appreciate you
coming out here Mike no problem thank
you very much all right so obviously you
saw so far the application of IOT in
machine learning and real-life client
study what's in the future
as we think about the future we can talk
about a lot of things that we can do
with IOT and ml together whether it is
in the era of manufacturing for a domain
of manufacturing or you know putting
automation robotics or whether it
transforming service industry or
building smarter cities as Mike alluded
to so I'll throw some light on a couple
of these cases and then we'll have some
time for Q&A and towards the end so just
take an example of the service industry
using the concepts that we have talked
about predictive maintenance IOT and ml
they can be different business models so
one of them is asset as a service so
instead of selling equipment you're
serving so you're just offering capacity
so just as the software the service
asset of the service and where you are
able to predict time to failure you are
able to find whether the machine has
degraded fine anomalies there and
thereby you can improve the
profitability of your warranty deals
like there are companies which
specialize in this now this has also an
added advantage of moving from capex to
OPEX and the financial CFO's actually
loved this concept whereby you are able
to capitalize another model is usage
based insurance now this is where the
behavior of the driver comes in handy if
you are able to track by putting a
special device like what geotab has
those devices have ability to their
sensors and they have the ability to not
only store the various parameters they
can find out if the driver was rash if
he was he or she was there were some
potholes on the road so all of that can
be used to either incentive
a particular set of users in a
particular zip code and obviously there
are privacy concerns so a lot of this
thing is generalized and offered as a as
a different model and this pricing model
is actually disrupting the insurance
industry another example in the service
industry is benchmarking as a service so
obviously when you are collecting all
this kind of data or reliability data
from products when the sensors are
talking and how you are consolidating
feedback to the product manufacturers on
this data and predictive insights can be
provided to others in the same industry
or in other industries as well and this
benchmarking helps in future product
development and also provides
comparative insights so that's the
service industry let's talk about
smarter cities
I don't know about you but I feel that
the cities are getting crowded we need
to do something about it right and as
per some studies done by United Nations
we will see upsurge in city population
over the next 50 years and resources in
cities would be constrained a lot now
how do we make sure that these resources
are not being wasted so the art of the
possible is at the intersection of IOT
and ml and how do we change the world by
improving the life of current people
like us so how do we make these cities
better again we talked about sensors and
interconnected IOT devices so there's a
real-time monitoring that can happen
powered by cloud analytics and ml now
this is some way whereby city planners
can get data about the city's roads and
they can find out which roads are
congested in real time and device
mechanisms to alert and divert traffic
they can find
out utilities utilities can find out
from the sensors what pipes are about to
leak and thereby instead of fixing the
problem you can send preventive crews
ahead of time so and so forth so
structure health is covered there is
fire safety things and also about air
pollution so all in all this is
something which we are very passionate
about and our client here geotab is also
venturing into smaller cities so I hope
this presentation has given you an idea
of the potential of predictive
maintenance the industry examples and
the demo we showed gives you a bird's
eye view of how IOT since the data can
be used with machine learning and how
they are using it today and they are
looking at building the better world
with smarter manufacturing smarter
services and smaller cities so we will
hang around for some questions
towards the end and thank you well for
very much for coming here there are some
resources at the back of this deck you
will find I'm inviting you to the IOT
track showcase as well as to spring Mel
booth in Moscone West one three three
eight is the booth number please swing
by and of course will all four of us are
here if you would like to swing by and
talk and have your questions thank you
you
[Music]